that's pete davidson documenting his
recent hangout with scott disick and now
a source is telling e.t all about the
pair's budding bromance i mean i think
you just gotta figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day
of course the pair met through pete's
girlfriend kim kardashian whom he
started dating in october and scott
you'll recall previously dated kim's
sister courtney and they share three
kids together now that the buddies have
linked up our source says scott likes
having someone like pete in his corner
because he's not exactly cool with
court's engagement to travis barker
quote scott is still not totally into
them as a couple and it is hard for him
and it seems with pete now in the
kardashian family's inner circle lord
disick is having a good time the source
adds scott and pete have fun together
when they hang out they are both funny
and chill and they've developed a
friendship they feel like they can grow
out with each other case in point check
out this video when the snl star took
over scott's instagram
dinner let alone make story on the table
but somehow i just want to do that i
just want to like dance i just want to
like you know
put on some shirelles i just i want to
be black
yeah pete reveals he's the last one
awake showing scott and some other pals
asleep in front of a tv the comedian
jokingly adds the caption boy's night
was wild i love her and when pete isn't
growing out with scott he's spending
time with kim and her family the source
says the king of staten island star has
been getting closer with the famous fam
and he's been enjoying hanging out with
everyone quote he's all about vibin who
he vibes and is very open and accepting
of everyone kim loves that about him
it's really lit and fun and crazy and it
seems the couple is closer than ever
so close that pete made things permanent
he posted this
selfie sort of
right and and there's they're reading
into it saying that there's a tattoo
that says kim
um yeah he has a few tattoos a few cute
ones you know that he got um but this
one is a it's not that one the kim one
isn't a tattoo it's actually a branding
like a
branding that's right kim revealed the
comedian has a branding of her name on
his chest when you say branding so like
literally like an iron thing yes went on
to his body yes to brand kim yes uh-huh
he's like i don't want to be able to get
rid of it or to cover it up and i just
wanted it like there as like a scar
on me where you're so cute guys it is
cute it's adorable and that smile on
kim's face says it all our source says
that the skim's founder is enjoying her
relationship with pete and she feels
like she is having fun with him like she
never has before she feels so relaxed
around him and like her true self things
are getting more and more serious
between them
[Music]